oh no no no no no no no oh my God will
throw a shopping cart at her at her face
too what would drive a man so cold
according to him he did it because she
was calling him gay
he's like Gaylord okay Lord wow damn
well you can't do that officer you
wouldn't believe what she called me I
fully sympathize
the only way this is Justified is if he
actually was gay because then he's
fighting against a hate crime then you
know what I didn't dude I didn't see him
ground in the water
with
a
hey your hips move oh my hands
kill the character I mean as a guy we
all can identify with what he was going
through a little bit I fought somebody
because they called me gay for real
I'll try to be cool man like I was
trying to sell it